well the stage is all set allowing all
but the ccsd
school kids to play football leaders of
clark county saying no sports until
face-to-face instruction
as for the winter sports as john treat
shows us tonight
they've already been blindsided shut out
and forced to make decisions
that's pretty hard to find a winner they
are durango kids
not allowed to play at durango high
school and not allowed to compete in
nevada
high school only get four years and all
years to me are valuable
48 states have a plan to play winter
sports
some haven't started some have over a
month left
nevada is one of two to not even take a
shot
we're sorry time has simply run out on
the winter
sports season and the basketball and
wrestling seasons
are are now officially over we're doing
it now we're just doing it outside of
ccsd
so i don't see why it couldn't be pulled
off with the extra resources that they
do have
the durango boys are blazing a trail in
nearly every western state that isn't
nevada
as fees and travel take a toll because
you have to travel every other weekend
just to go play in a tournament but
sometimes i just want to play in vegas
you know it could give me a scholarship
it could get me
to college for free the parents are
fighting for their kids future when
you're looking at the social the
physical emotional mental
this is part of their makeup not one of
us who's played sports
does not have a friend that we still
talk to that was on our junior high high
school or college teams
and i worked out with some of the other
players just to give them an outlet
hopping fences and working out for an
hour
you know on concrete you know but they
needed that
why did the buzzer sound so quick in
nevada testing
discipline and sacrifices have been made
everywhere else i feel like we'll all be
with the program
you know if anything we could do to stay
here and play basketball here
we're willing to do it john treach 8
sports now